[Musique]
oui
m
ou pas
pour l'aïe
oh
[Musique]
chanteur paynter acteurs lighters night
clubbers et newcomers tous à l'heure ils
sont tous là pour la revue de fin
d'année c'est le destop de lunettes
noires pour nuits blanches plus les dix
exclus qui ont marqué la saison gaston
le meilleur meilleur tu as fait ça dit
cap est avant tout un petit mot pour
tous les là tout
[Musique]
la technique l'hérault
jean noël watts
pasadena
hellmuth derrière
l'arc est
bon gabillon
françoise hardy
clip est encore
sa borne
millions
de
ménages
et aita mitsouko
david et johnatan soul sister
serge gainsbourg ou mcenroe mac
béatrice dalle
lxb genoa à piran strand arbitres
margaux hemingway
johnny ford à
maxime le forestier
nicolas elle fanning canada
six mois sega
mega
tout est sérieux
at il dit quoi atteint quand tu sors d
éval d'être regardant la
digue un jeu m'a dit m'a dit
mettez ça peut être à part tes oreilles
il ya eu but
qui changerait quoi elle
indiqué est ce que mon cher thot
[Musique]
je changerais
bunge est que
plus moquer ivre
et du change
[Musique]
rechargeable
huit coups et un quotidien
sur des petits quand tu étais un nom
venu
tu voulais ressembler que je connais une
phase de picabia qui dit moi monsieur je
me déguise en homme pour n'être rien
tbb là
c'est sûr insidieuse
à strasbourg dans les parent qui t'ai vu
mourir comme john lennon
imagine
tu as des couilles
c'était pas de l'intrépidité c'est du
courage parce que la stabilité sur le
carreau
charge
la question
le courage c'est de vaincre sa peur
[Musique]
où elle est mon petit gars ce verre
gbagbo
[Musique]
tu penses que tu vas mourir quand
pour bientôt 1 soit pas de mathématiques
quand je vais trouver
sur un coup
j'espère c'est que s'envoyer en l'air
mais sans louper sens en envoyant un
curé quand même
ce qu'il faut class classe classe
qu'un jour tu es 10
du feu ne porteront pas trop con
l'homme a créé les dieux demain gers
reste à prouver de toujours atterrir
non je crois que je vis un
politis mme
à dire je mets toujours est dû au
pluriel de peur est requis qui le
promenait
dans mauvaises nouvelles des étoiles
j'ai dit dieu
c'est tout simple jésus est de race et
me
l a dit je suis
fils de dieu
est en train
en 1942
tu as envie france fait savoir que j'ai
eu une étoile de shérif
géant le poids à la wehrmacht plus tu es
beau mec qui faisait d'occupation j'en
veux aux miliciens au foie jaune et
prescriptions
par un coup
c'est vrai que paris hier pendant une
perquisition
peut-être cacher quelques kilomètres
dans l'adoption de la
carte d'état-major
dixit
oui j'ai eu des sursis d'aurélie elle
s'éteint avec l'important coucou
et prix nicole
échos petits pots qu'on qui mènera
sûrement l'envié mais m
qui a écoulé le titanic
iceberg en corée
tout est à un nazi très quoi comme
magique
elle est bonne celle là
cet homme celui-ci aurait dîné encore un
juif de moi
c'était une infirmité
chemiser c'est quoi
certes été interdite et le souhait
je suis dit a eu je
veux savoir les ailes tout ce qui se
passe
dans ce paysage c'est bien et j'étais
été un poison
ciguë c'est du tout de suite tu prends
ça ça les poids morts
tu penses à bon train
pas trop ah bon j'ai pas d'argent est la
ville où est la seule arme que tu es
chez toi c'est une sorte quoi
et comme tu la mets sur la table on
pense pas que tu t'en sers vraiment pas
certain je sème a été donnée par le père
de kent
carisse
la dernière seuls les officiers blessés
avaient droit à cette saignée dans poule
2 en film et deviens de pompey touareg
sûrs et souffrant 15 ans c'est vraiment
fou et british à ses oeuvres tout ça oui
perfide albion est un accident
et plus il est bien vrai le hindenburg
là le truc nagy qui s'est scratché sur
new york
city du rap avant la journée mais si tu
étais une cicatrice
est interdit à
pierre si les travail
on voit
chez pour y arriver
équilibre neige dans le métier
il faut que je prenne ouais maintenant
j'ai eu des travaux publics
cela me disais que c'est beaucoup de blé
il
enfin je pense que je range et parfois
je suis au rouge non
je suis renseigné un des derniers grands
chez germaine du 19
octobre dans un hôtel
pour en cours ou à des jets privés
ci devient marginale
j'ai pas fini
ah oui encore quelques bons coups
ati avec bambou
il ya une arrêt avec le foot de club
dans l'oeil
qui n'est pas un âge où une touriste et
fait un shampoing et shanghai ou
bien le fils de son père lui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
ap
[Musique]
deux poupées
m
[Musique]
ça
d
pour les
[Musique]
2 m
m
tu crois que tu serais avec les sucettes
la rencontrer
je pense que surpris
m
j'ai compris demi heure m
rencontre
on a coeur à coeur
ça suffit une perse
on
on reste assis toi
oracle est le dernier de la dernière de
ma p'tite cocotte minute
voire et toi tu ferais quoi
bon la région s'étaient pas rencontrés
je sais pas du tout s'est passé sur le
corps lave et à plein de choses que
c'est pas vous aurez eu un destin
complètement différent je sais pas
j'ai marqué au fer rouge là est la
benjamine
qu'est-ce que tu t'énerves le plus chez
moi
des sautes du rdr électrocardiogramme tu
peux parler je n'ai pas et pire que moi
je tiens déjà cassé une bombe
c'est râpé pas le soumissionnaire
[Musique]
mais moi je suis un lâche j'ai rappelé
moi je prends les boutons
du couteau plus alléchant ttone
tu ferais quoi cgt qui tu es
bien sûr
parmi
les neuf
sites du kit eh ben
je dis et je répète que tu serais pas la
première
tu sais peut-être la dernière
[Musique]
où
c'est pas mal hein parce que
toutes les pinces
accroché au radiateur
comment
il ya fatale
un chien
tu bouges pas de l'air
[Musique]
cette affiche est qu en chaîne s'est
tiré avec très
[Musique]
commun
accord
[Musique]
toutefois
avec état que j'habite
à dire malvy ps
c'est vrai qu'au début des années 60
était marié avec une princesse quality
garçons
pour partager en deux
mais
une gare
avec qui tu as eue
d'un simple coup de maître et la
question ps
je ne vais pas rester plus souvent parce
que tu as les
barbe est ce que c'est et maryse ici
qu'est
ce que c'est que
c'est un seul clic
à partir du moment où tu t'es marié que
ça commence là
déconnecte pour cette étude fournit à
l'école
tu n'aimes
pas non plus
assez
fascinant rufin pour ce qu'elles ne sont
très déçus parce que je
respecte ça
cette espèce est je ne laisserai pas
[Musique]
je te prends toi en france mais tu n'es
pas mais ce n'est pas aussi parce que tu
es
spread baby y avait deux
questions
marcel lesur crémant ouste
quel est pour toi le comble la misère
de passer inaperçu
moi j'aurais dit absence de papier cul
oui c'est moi qui fais le test seconde
question le port à cheval ou un mauvais
coup et moi tu vivre à las vegas
vous parce que
parce que j'ai passé une semaine génial
je me dis comme partout où je me suis
fait chier candidats la saga ça serait
bien
elle tue pas plus chier avec tes jouets
franglais ai pas beaucoup vu c'est pas
trop dur mais c'était marrant ce joli
conte si t'as pas tu n'as tu pas parce
que c'est ce qui inquiète c'est pas
grave je n'ai pas perdu beaucoup
[Musique]
d'efforts chemin
ouais français vacances dont l'idéal de
bonheur que la page
je dois pas en mangeant puisque je m'en
mets en partout mais avec du foïer vais
pas être obligés de travailler quoi même
n'importe quoi tu abordes tu te mac avec
bah oui mais ceux avec qui je me sens
jamais de blé alors la malbaie ils ont
abîmé
les beaux gosses ils sont pas forcément
plein de tri
pour quelle faute tu veux plus
d'indulgence
on habite ici parce qu'il y en a
tellement que je suis obligée de me
faire
[Musique]
je réduis foot j'en trouve ta qualité
préféré je suis là
philou sa gueule qu'on a dans brouille
parce que son émoi que ce soit moi qui
les fasse
et c'est la fin
je sais pas j'aime pas pour les formes
heureusement foulard qualité et d'une
femme et d'un gars l'était pas qu'est-ce
que tu meurs en toi
je suis gentille ils l'ont tué
elvis la route un
moment j'ai pas entendu des ulis la gtt
des cieux mais c'est aussi un petit peu
que tu en occupation préférée est facile
parce que ça j'en ai pas d occupation
cofor disent que tu existes du bourg ain
touta joyeux mineurs n'ont souvent et
anvers
je sais pas manger
la veuve poignet maintenant que ça va
rester
quel serait ton plus grand malheur
il
être obligé d'avoir un travail tous les
jours
voilà
face à la couleur que tu préfères
[Musique]
rbb j'aime bien vers buvait y
est il mal en quoi ton valoir qu'ils ont
conçu les
mois j'aurais dit kaka doigt parce que
ça souvenu
le don de la nature que tu aimerais
avoir
[Musique]
je suis très bien comme ça alors
finalement c'est vers quoi
jouer de la musique oui ça dans la
nature en sarouel
et ben moi c'est faire caca soir aux
deux
passes et classe
comment aimerais-tu mouy je ne veux pas
mourir un talent à l'appel je ne sais
pas je me suis pas posé la question je
n'ai pas du tout eu aucun plaisir
amoureux
moi je vais mourir vivant
the last one
quelle est l'étape est alors retourné ce
prix
les anges ah oui présenté un chrono
présent
je sais pas ça va
et elle
s'appelle souvent fond mais là ça
[Musique]
m
mais
[Musique]
m
de là
[Musique]
m
qu'est il est
souvent génération sly stone
elle est vraiment décevant de l'espoir
qu'il y ait un moment - à
2010 doit être créé
afin qu'ils peuvent maintenant offrir ou
9 novembre comment est né ce pas
seulement
vaincre aux claouey et au thorax
turinois issus des réseaux twitter et de
logistique elle est comprise comme une
ombre for ever
is involved in spirituality n1m sexe à
youtube
afin qu'on peut accuser
et
pour
cela
l'accent
sur
l'os
windows live
chez
d-link france gall
il avait réitéré des millions
[Musique]
qu'est
ce
[Musique]
qui
t'as pas l'impression que
indochine c'est un groupe qu'elle ait du
succès qui qu'après après été obligés
d'assurer
non je crois qu'on a été obligés a
effectivement de découvert certaines
phases 2
ouais on nous a mis devant la vie pour
l'avouer
pas assimiler le succès mais c'est un
truc est difficile moi c'est assez
minable parce que c'est pas tout mettre
je te soigne après on s'est plus ou
moins torride progrès
j'ai pas eu l'impression pas ce que
c'est
saab y quatre ans mais il ira on avait
quand même ramené dans différents
groupes c'est vrai que bon indochine
dessus d'un marché ce qui est difficile
on a su mettre effectivement c'est
apprendre
à être sur scène alors qu'on a été jeté
sans faiblir ans s'est jeté sur 500 sont
exactement comme un acquis intéressant
et on n'apprend pas il n'y a pas une
école cydia nan je sais pas si c'est toi
du groupe dit mais qu'est ce qu'on y
peut ça marche on n'y peut rien c'est
tombé sur c'est vrai ça c'est comment
dire c'est une interview type et qui
était prise tu vois la toile alors oui
les personnes dialysées affaire secrète
et vous fais pas tu penses que vous avez
fait des progrès en sept ans
pour moi ouais je veux dire pourquoi je
sais pas
on est à vous a par exemple c'est qu'on
dit content du chanvre ou est-ce que tu
as l'impression de plus j'en ai mots
ce n'est pas une foi qui fait que
quoique un peu handicapé
j'aime et je sens parfois dans le sens
e
beaucoup merki
les bancaires albert ferrasse
non mais c'est pas par exemple dans
cette famille article de libé oui
une auris et diana du groupe qui avait
dit on fait de la mayonnaise c'est vrai
ou c'est pas vrai
c'est vrai on fait de la mayonnaise
marque et la mayonnaise mais c est ce
que c'est vrai qu'à un membre du groupe
cadets ont fait de la mayonnaise
qu'on avait expliqué en disant
qu'effectivement ça n'est pas très bien
ce qu'on faisait se dire qu'on faisait
on mettait des santé on était une boîte
à ripon bt une fois amateurs toutefois
il me tarde que c'était entre du
rock'n'roll du match 1 de la rame ce qui
faisait une sorte de mayonnaise ouaibe
attitré ils font des rocs mayonnaise
[Musique]
on est là
ça
la ville
e
[Musique]
le
ou pas
[Musique]
comment
et
ce qu'est ce que
le
g
oui
[Musique]
m
et là
tha
[Musique]
ce que tu crois pas que tu le voulais
changer le monde explique finalement
c'est le monde qui est à changer
oui ça c'est vrai que j'ai pas changer
le monde mais je constate un monde mais
beaucoup changé non plus je pense que je
vois c'est que c'est toujours un truc un
peu utopiste mais un peu dingue comme ça
tu te rappelles sur un nuage et que je
me sens finalement très bien c'est
toujours antimilitariste
un peu moins depuis que vous allez à
beyrouth ouais et anti nucléaires
un peu moins depuis que j'ai rencontré
deux généraux qui ont expliqué que les
plus acides c'était peut-être les
centrales au chili avant
il ya une chose qui m'a beaucoup surpris
le dos je t'ai vu dans une émission de
télévision
on parlait tout à l'heure de la
télévision et tu étais chez patrick
sébastien
et tu t'étais déguisant mourousi avec un
costume trois pièces les lunettes et une
perruque et un pantalon tout jeune à
cambrai
je suis pas trois mais toi à la place de
gens qui ont aimé tes chansons qu'ils
ont passé des nuits entières sur des
sons des platines sur des pick up je
trouve pas que pour eux c'est terrible
de voir faire ça à la télé pendant que
j'espère qu'ils sont là et s'ils sont
pas marrer c'est qu'on est pas d'accord
les autres
toujours dit que c'était un saltimbanque
penseurs c'est pas un philosophe à mieux
de philosophes grecs et les bouquins de
toute façon moi j'aimerais bien voir duc
manh bernard henri lévy faire les cons
que sébastien sur loire il est
dramatisée un peu l'ensemble s'apparente
de fait un truc comme ça non non non
saltimbanques non sérieux jura non non
saltimbanque je suis prêt à le refaire
quand il veut
déguisé en vieille mathieu s'il sera
toujours là vu sacha distel enchaîne en
fera toujours marrer sa maman est folle
se déguiser moi j'ai pas mal vécue au
brésil
se déguiser au brésil se travestir c'est
normal que dans la campagne électorale
j'étais en pleine campagne électorale
les présidentiables devaient danser la
samba devant les caméras sont éteintes
les 28 mois j'ai sérieusement ça m'a mis
un peu mal à l'aise parce que je me suis
dit finalement si maxime le forestier
n'avait pas été un chanteur
contestataire dans les fin des 60 depuis
les soixante dix et s'il avait été agent
d'assurances il aurait cette tête là
c'est à dire de vos rosiers
en plus plus de cheveux tu veux mais un
peu un peu gros comme ça avec un costume
trois pièces se mettait mal à l'aise
peut-être même que pour les victoires de
la musique je veux retirer un jeune
patient tout est agrémenté prêt à faire
de la pub par exemple tel que tu es
parti je viens tu fais jamais fait j'en
est vrai qu'aux musiciens wii nommé je
n'apparais septembre mais en
apparaissant je suis me pose juste une
triple tu vois bien que tu as changé
tout
en haut
de gamme comme bernard foucher chose à
te dire
ciudad real et audio
en cas de
[Rires]
divorce
des new began to tout livre de l'anglais
il ajoute c'est big and to bring to
smoke
[Rires]
[Musique]
wikileaks qui a
terni d'un auteur de l'essai de lister
lors de la journée
haïku dembélé vite aux yeux du wild eyes
and like this guy lauzon
titre la caliber des sites comme ebay
[Rires]
[Musique]
la vision
dames
[Musique]
château d'eau
et
hélas
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
washington
la
bourre tout juste mais je fais ce nom
business
is never
say
[Musique]
never
est
[Musique]
tout près de là avec mon iphone
et le macbook air
[Musique]
il s'agirait d'un go c'est bon c'est la
crise grave existe deux sexy bouchées
doubles et clapping music bodinat toute
ma vie la cuisine romaine il a atteint
les 1 dijon 12
est dit glam est la chine made man et my
big red one who do what is it à baggio
du groupe mais goldman d'accueil
would you do you
do
débit
wifi
et c'est bon
tout est là
elle
aucune stèle begins
- vous devez toute la salle oui
[Musique]
hier
2 pékin est
cette fille de salon
ans
pourquoi
m
les routes
l'annoncé
m
[Applaudissements]
cette année
pourquoi
m
m m
le matin
c avant 3
ses dépens
que ce soit je bois
ces placements ne pas
parler
jamais fait et question
aidera c'est fini à laon
c'est grave c'est fini
en temps il ya 2 jours 2
tentation
tant m
commencez à voir monter d'escorté
et pan
dans une longue histoire
bah les caves des crédits
ou les
là
les choses
les airs en mer il est vrai mais à
avec le cinéma
j'étais avec un intérim
j'ai l'âme assuré annette
à l'étranger
il a vraiment enfance à des souris je ne
dis rien du tout les des années a
détruit
d
et ce pont d'ain
bourbeau
o o
mais après
ce
lavez pas prendre
une restauration mais un jour jacques
non mais vraiment
un peu des deux je sais plus riches
- angoissé est-ce que tu n'es pas est
trop cher
je veux pas revoir
la question que ça m'avait plu
longtemps
et photo c
tienne
des fruits
lama
les accords
remedial hockin les cornes c'est pas
qui dit
je sais pas
des maris c'est vrai
jour
[Musique]
à
c'est pas les passer et de sel
au genou
trois à gauche
et plus
et encore
je
que je passais
histoire
ah
bon
les projets n'ont jamais les projets
est ce qu'elle est
bon j'ai alors je suis pas mais vous
le cas
roger
[Musique]
mounir gondjout
secrétaire du parti a dû expliquer à
[Musique]
nous
bonjour bonsoir les six ans
est à l'essai pour l'honneur un cargo de
nuit qu'elle apparaisse date le parc des
sports en effet ça ne rigole démocrates
comme japan expo
[Musique]
non nous ne
connaissons
ni la
liberté
[Musique]
texmed
cynthia
ascame
jacques
chirac attributions
e
[Musique]
plus
m
on a
[Musique]
ok
côté d'ici
[Musique]
m
g
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
est ce que c'est
oui
moi je sais
[Musique]
mais que moi
[Applaudissements]
m
oui
hélas
[Musique]
la mairie
messieurs
vous
ce soir
[Musique]
op
imagine que tu puisses avoir quelque
chose en plus en plus en plus tu
préfèrerais avoir donné
le sexe et trois yeux
je crois que jacques préférait que les
deux sexes de
dymagym que tu sois enceinte de nouveau
oui quelle chance sur les plaisirs ah
ouais j'ai fait une échographie ou bout
et on te dit voilà votre petit
mais il a deux sexes il a donné où il ya
trois yeux qu'est ce que tu ferais tu te
ferait avorter ou tu le garderais parce
que finalement c'est que là c'est comme
ça je regarderai pas tu gardais pas tu
fais comme hitler alors que tu te tue
les gens qui sont pas normaux qua non
mais je crois qu'on est effectivement là
on avait les moyens
d'empêcher un être d'avoir une vie
vraiment
défavorisés
il faut utiliser ces moyens oui tu
rentres chez toi soir et tu trouves
jacques dutronc au lit avec isabelle
adjani mais ton message
tu joues à paris match
je me joins à eux ils mettaient le voilà
trois ans isabelle je n'ai rien contre
les amours saphiques alors servir dans
ces conditions-là qu'isabelle adjani ça
va oui de la condition que j'assure la
bosnie
vous séparer avec jacques ce triste ou
séparé
le pauvre thomas il se retrouve tout
seul pourquoi ça tout seul si on se doit
aussi enfin pour tout le monde se sépare
il faut le confier à quelqu'un c'est un
jeu est-ce que tu préférais qu'il soit
confié à karen cheryl à chantal goya ou
à dorothée
axa s'est insurgé sur wii un dilemme
je ne sais pas du tout je sais déjà toi
sale mère nourricière à qui voudrait
tuer soit confiée mais je crois je
confie à chantal goya parce que c'est la
seule que je connaisse des talents c'est
la seule qui ait eu des enfants ouais
saviez la télé en plus chantal goya donc
elle ce qui pourrait du moins c'est bon
ça en cela je crois qu'il faudrait
surtout demandé 1 victoire en
l'occurrence ah bon je crois qu'il
préférait se passer maintenant je vais
poser une question encore plus con c'est
possible tu es tu prisonnière
et les gens qui te tiennent comme ça
géôliers t'oblige à faire l'amour avec
un animal terry s'est jamais pensé
laisser croire non ça jamais tu vas y
penser pour la première fois ce soir il
était temps à ton âge est ce que tu
préfèrerais un cochon est un cochon
on verra au cochon
un chien ou un homme
tout en temps de réfléchir on a le temps
là vraiment c'est
là c'est quand même moins bien qu
isabelle est génial c'est autre chose
que la ville réserve taïwan selon
certains j'aime beaucoup les annonces
être évidemment je prendrai la briche
prendre un accord c'est bien c'est bien
le corps
vous avez appelé à 10,3 alors maintenant
si tu devais dîner avec quelqu'un t'a
pas le choix j'ai été obligé dîner avec
le heat a pas d'autre solution
tu préfèrerais dîner avec un sourd muet
ou avec un aveugle bed
je suis bien
il aveugle aux mecs mais ce que je
pourrais partir
par imagine que tu partes dans un
vaisseau spatial à mon avis là tu es
supporter bon là tu pars dans un
vaisseau spatial sur mars 4 en
juillet ouais également nous seuls tu as
le choix d'une pp qui tu choisis
dorothée ou chantal qu'ailleurs
ige dorothée
alors toujours le vaisseau spatial ouais
la review là il ya plus de pépé qu'est
ce tu préfères un mec ou la main gauche
la main gauche et des maladresses qui
rappelle celle d'une main étrangère je
recrée
mecque pour m e que tu préfères le mec
pour quatre ans dans le vaisseau spatial
qui préfère le mettre en oeuvre
alors imagine qu'en 89 la terreur ne
recommence pas tout se passe bien et
juste des commémorations mais que toi
par contre on propose un dit on dit
voilà philippe léotard vous lourds est
instantanément mais grâce à ça on va
trouver un vaccin pour soigner tous les
gens qui ont le sida qu'est-ce que tu
préfère mourir on retrouve jamais grecs
sont
tous les jours au dessus d'un gilet
rencontre et ils sont tous très
sympathiques maison pilori de leurs
fruits aux autres
donc je suis pas sûr que j'ai
enregistrée à l'élection alors dis-moi
tu préfèrerais vivre dans un pays libre
mais très très très très pauvres ou dans
une dictature où il ya un très très très
haut niveau dit par exemple je préfère à
une pause dans la reprise tu préfères
être dans un pays libre non je suis pas
d'accord imagine que tu es un milliard
2000 milliards de milliards temps frais
quoi
mais bolt
hockey
les troyens way tabak ouais alcool ouais
[Musique]
et elle sera encore des milliards de
milliards jetés avant je tais tu verrais
fine campagne électorale à ton frère par
exemple il peut crever la gueule ouverte
je paierai pas des campagnes électorales
à personne je trouve que du gaspillage
ayachi je lui ai dit de prendre douter
si j'avais mois seulement faire
confiance ouais
[Musique]
à qui du haut de la vallée
et
de là
elle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous allons
[Musique]
et
tu
m
[Musique]
wen hui là
adieu
d
à
mais bon
star
[Applaudissements]
houga
[Musique]
sow
on est
jo
c'est
nasa devait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tél
et
là
[Applaudissements]
b
ou pas
hu
tu es obligé de faire l'amour avec un
mec c'est un jeu
que vous êtes vraiment avec un mec t'as
choisir entre deux mecs qui préfère quil
geste pas aux jupes et
ses intérêts comme question est les deux
à la fois potable et de la peinture
al'inverse on te dit voilà maintenant
vous avez le choix pendant les dix
prochaines années
soit vous n'avez plus de sexe du tout
c'est quand même pas le droit de ne même
pas la fille de la navette spatiale même
s'ils n'ont pas pris la tâche et je vois
pas de sexe pendant dix ans j'ai battu
son nom n'est plus maintenant non non je
ne peux pas le faire même toi
même toit mais bon c'est sa première
solution une deuxième solution tu ne
manges plupart en disant c'est à dire
nourris avec des dés sont des piqûres
des machins des trucs qu est ce que tu
préfère ne pas avoir de cette barre de
bouffer en disant
ah oui absolument 47 pendant dix ans et
avoir là pourtant le taux a non mais
alors il coûte alors préféré parce que
de toute façon dans ma tête qui se
passait des choses ni au camp vrai jeu
peut-être dit sur moi dans ta tête et
bain pendant dix ans je serai dans ma
technique pas d'antécédents la caisse
ici au québec c'est dans la tête à la
lorraine en tout cas avec lui sur l'île
déserte arrive à roissy il ya le
douanier couche cavalli qu'est ce qui te
gêne le plus qu'ils trouvent à
l'intérieur de la balise mein kampf ou
un godemiché
rien du tout alors il faut trouver steve
des tonnes de de capotes usagers ou pas
mannequins font face alors les doigts ni
parce qu'on est ce qu'ils veulent avant
tout les emballages vraiment les
emmerdes même si son entier mais je les
adore les entier pour fumer un pétard à
la maison d'accord match est pas un mec
te trompes tu t'aperçois qui 30 qu'est
ce que tu préfères comme vengeance lui
lui crever les yeux avec une perceuse
électrique
ou alors lui tronçonné le sexe avec une
tronçonneuse électrique
témoin qui
habite
je vais me dit écoute je ne fais pas
parce que parce que vraiment eu crève
les yeux qu'une personne je les
transcende le sexe et qu'une personne
n'en avait que 30 ans à la conversion
des tronçonneuses s'est
exclamé que alors vraiment je pense que
je sois beaucoup plus que ça ah bon mais
je pense que j'irai pas dépasser cette
maîtresse mais je pense avoir volé sa
maîtresse je pense que ce serait
vraiment la plus grande des banques
c'est une bonne réponse c'est pas
vraiment bouddhiste qu'enfin je dis ah
bon tu as quand même flirter avec le
bouddhisme et tu crois la fin car nation
oui bon alors si tu étais un carnet est
ce que tu préfères être interné en jean
jean pierre foucault
patrick sabatier où michel drucker
heureusement que tu étais pas citer
parce qu'alors vraiment le dernier
mais en tout cas écoute moi je pense pas
comprise comme ça des cendres de
conditions moi je
ferai car mes deux fois dit non à la
prochaine elizabeth taylor a bon j'ai
trahi ça va leur faire plusieurs mamans
entre les trois tous là répondre âgées
entre sabatier de rigueur il faut qu il
a bien régime ce soit obligatoire c'est
un jeu
mais coûte tu sais en plus moi j'ai de
la tendresse pour l'e3 est plus
particulier plus particulièrement pour
sabatier drucker fait plus de dix massés
sur leurs actes en écoutaient ce que je
ne sais pas la tt legends les jeux
alors maintenant la bombe arrive en 5
minutes ou la radio un matin tech ta
fille tombe à arriver tous les trois la
maison un brio mais ciel avis on te dit
la bombe va tomber dans cinq minutes
qu'est ce que tu fais pendant les cinq
dernières minutes comme disait
l'inspecteur boel ce prix c'est bien
tu crois la réincarnation
de samedi croyons au rayon des deux
minutes est-ce que tu préférais être
réincarné en fer à repasser
en machine à laver ou un inspirateur
été obligé de répondre cela fait pas
fausse il s'adonne à la chasse en plaine
moi j'ai les bouquets n'y a pas besoin
non non non non ça c'est pas possible on
fait un vin sec et suit m'a dit
aspirateur machine à laquelle tout
simplement en faire un passé tu préfères
fait avant parce que ça fait des
caresses aux gens la voient pas ce que
ça peu et tout et ça peut être une basse
attendant les comptes ils aspirent les
conneries toute la journée long qui
l'avait conneries des noms mais voilà
donc le faire remplacer voir imagine
deux minutes que tu prends entreprend il
faut toujours du magic day c'est un jeu
paru dans l'imaginaire j'imagine que tu
apprends qu est ce que tu reproches ray
le plus à dieu tout
mais allons-y tout prenant des exemples
précis carrefour est ce que c'est le
reprocherait d'avoir ministre au nom d'
finalement rika zaraï
bad et souza ah oui marie france cuba da
qui est pas mal non plus je te la
conseil il est obligé la non mais là
tout le monde mais tout est moi non mais
on est vraiment mais c'est des questions
auxquelles tout le monde répond
seulement maintenant alors je répète
marie france cuba da linda de suza ou
rika zaraï qu'est ce que tu reproches de
plus au bon dieu d'avoir mis sur peur
mais non mais je reproche pas ça se
rapproche des trucs bien pire quotas toi
aussi tu as assez grave on trouve
vraiment à l'étroit que je condamne mais
c'est pas n'importe quoi ah
[Musique]
là là mais c'est en mer dans des
attentats sanglants sans bien sûr tous
grades d'assaut tous les trois du fret
est un plomb ou tu vois j'en sais rien
toutefois je m'étrangle robert oui
d'accord mais sur terre les trois pas
d'accord avec ce que tu sais pas tu fais
pas de jaloux elles sont toutes les
trois dans le même sac les alors
imaginons maintenant que tout survol
d'angleterre en avion oui bien sûr on
conviendra les deux moteurs
les moteurs sont en feu
l'avion va tomber puisque tout avion
survolant angleterre c'est un ratio or à
les deux moteurs ans se faisait d'un
accord c'est l'habitude on voit qu'il a
inventé ça et tout la qualité dans ce
que j'ai minutes
vous êtes trois dans l'avion seulement
oui
il ya deux parachutes
alors bon tampon ah bon bah oui non à
tapisser les deux autres drucker et
chance elles
n'ont pas plus claire et plus près de
mon avant d'accord donc tu donnes les
parachutes à briquet à tout usager
barras et est accroché un truc après tu
fais bien ton business est utile et
parachutes aux gens qui ont des
émissions de télé qu'est ce tu veux non
mais c'est bien quand tu fais beaucoup
enfin c'est plutôt drucker quand même tu
choisis mais qu'un avatar 30 tous les
samedis non mais c'est pas non c'est pas
ça non mais non c'est pas une histoire
de 20h37 est plutôt une histoire d'âge
pas
non dont elle s'acquitte réacteurs se
levant les passionnés de leurs mandants
dernière question une tradition si tu
veux voir dans cette émission c'est le
vaisseau spatial
tu dois partir dans un vaisseau spatial
parce que c'est une histoire qui dure
d'édition à l'unisson il lui a participé
dans un vaisseau spatial où es tu
tu peux choisir ses quatre ans le centre
spatial c'est pas de la rigolade ces
quatre ans que la même personne
d'or est plutôt servir à rien en
apesanteur pendant quatre ans avec la
même personne tarek après j'ai vu ce
qu'on a l'habitude d'avoir des affaires
et quitté 1 est ce que tu pourrais faire
partir attention ans d'école avec france
gall
lara 4
véronique sanson a cette touche m oui
c'est un jeu hier à kemal monopoly c'est
la rue de la paix je viens je dois en
choisir une des trois et on est que
toutes les deux pendant quatre ans en
apesanteur tous les catholiques avaient
toutes les deux auquel tu choisis
avec soin parce que sans ça on a choisi
la ramsi l'attaqué voir elle a dit
qu'elle prendra un petit maillot mais je
sais où j'ai plutôt comme tant
qu'autorité tu vois jamais été avec moi
c'est toi que je suis pas forcément
complètement c'est mieux quelques acquis
voire un peu d'apprentissage alors ses
inventions la ans a priori non véronique
nonon donc après le oui des gens
d'expérience ou non la roche plus en
triplettes
[Musique]
et
nos salles
mais non mais
[Musique]
[Rires]
m
non ça
[Musique]
m
oui
[Musique]
je sais pas
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
une amie
m
[Musique]
oui
il a nommé m
on appelle là
[Musique]
4energy équation s'étaient pas
rencontrés
je crois que j'aurais continué à être
interprète et puis
je pense mouais
catherine ringer que tu crois que je
ferais si j'étais si on ne s'était pas
en retrait et aurait trouvé quelqu'un
d'autre doit dire un autre chanteur ou
chanteuse qui est très obstiné beaucoup
plus que moi
catherine ringer c'est pas chien de
travail est toujours avec la même
personne c'est à dire d'être tout le
temps avec en studio sur scène partout
je sais par
catherine langeais c'est pas tellement
laryngite je sais quoi qui d'ailleurs le
plus chez moi
[Musique]
si jamais ri chez toi catherine ringer
il a réagi tandis la vie d'artiste c'est
triste c'est vrai il ya des hauts et des
bas ces cantons tous les métiers des
fois c'est terriblement triste et puis
des points on s'amuse comme des petits
fous c'est vrai dans un jour là hein
j'ai connu je parle avec lui je crois
qu'on va faire carrière ensemble
et
un jouet que ce serait si je te quitter
je
te suivrai
il est là comme une ombre
et moi c'est que ce chiffre est ton avis
mais je suis pas là un gîte est ce que
tu m'aimes
[Musique]
selon un sourire alors
et
pour les fêtes était en israël avec ta
mère je crois que c'est ma pensée
j'ai dit un truc
enfin franchement ce que j'appellerais
mais c'est que
en mars c'est la sécurité du bien
pour partir c'était
se faire fouiller les bagages et et
faire la queue d un deuxième bon ça
c'est assez
c'est normal
par contre que j'ai pas aimé ça j'étais
à jérusalem est
j'étais à thomas dit
connais pas
j'arrivais il plus riches en partie
visible parce que tu es là tu donc en
fait sur sur 12 jours de vacances j'en
ai pris j'ai pris cinq jours de soleil
je vois ça comme en l'avenir dans l'état
palestinien
carrément politique de zéro je connais
rien parce qu'ils soient séparés
victoire matthias poehm
c'est quand même bon ton pays en forme
au pays c'est pas ton pays mais c'est
quand même un pays important
je pense à ceux qui sont politiques sur
le papier vous n'êtes pas
je peux comprendre aussi que la
palestine sans contact pas donc j'ai pas
cette question c'est que ça maintient
ses
trucs et la pensée pour la politique et
tout ça c'est bon tu ferais quoi si on
s'était pas rencontré
tu travailleras avec mon père dans la
sphère des fruits et légumes à rungis
ouais je pense parce que
c'est une super bonne ambiance avant
les camions ça pas
dur à dire bien sûr voit on les punks
enfin droit je me suis sympa
et du moins et tu me poses ça mais toi
qu'il souffrait qu'histoire effet
ben moi je voulais faire du cinéma tu
crois qu'on a apporté quoi la chanson
française
pour l'instant oui
dire un truc je me la pose souvent des
questions mais je pense que
on a importé peut-être
des souvenirs aux jeunes
des souvenirs de vacances aux jeunes
on a apporté peut-être un peu inquiété
dans les familles s'est affinée est ce
que tu crois que ça nous a vachement
l'été tu t'appelles david marouani
c'est une très bonne question
je pense ma réponse mais tu peux passer
dans la pensée
je pense que
c'est difficile quand même vous avez du
métier bon c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que
quand le producteur emmené le disque aux
médias tout le monde savait que je
m'appelle david marouani donc dans un
sens c'était bien mon un sens c'était
pas bien basculer
le piston serait jamais dit moi est ce
que tu penses sincèrement
dans le droit des yeux tu dirais très
franchement est ce que tu penses qu'on
va continuer à chanter ensemble ouais
ouais on voit sa passe était moi je n'en
vois mais je pense que si on doive
ensemble si un jour ça marche plus et
que on en plus aucun disque est que
l'entente on n'est plus la même il
faudra songer
à se diversifier mais pour l'instant
tout va bien et
on va essayer de continuer à enfoncer le
clou
aucun nom
m
mon coeur et mon âme
non
gates
m
il boitait
oh
m
[Musique]
nous essayons de là mais qui pourra
ski
je
la vie
l eau
m
[Musique]
tu me suis
m
qui
le monde
les catacombes ma colombe aux abris
c'était tous les samedis
le métro avec silvano berger rond
c'était le nec plus ultra de l'avant
tour
[Musique]
la saint-michel madame nouvelle en 89
quel buzz
cirque archaos bros pour le best-of
circus bus
m
ton
rex soirée jungle avec de lessive
bailleul
hoballah skinheads or là ce soir et
jones ex latex 100 complet
chez madame arthur les travestis la nuit
c'était la face cache sexe de la vie
on glisse le french kiss i au palace
quelle place beauvau relic yoann folly
toujours au palace carnaval bacchanales
[Musique]
à l'école du cirque annie fratellini néo
punk gogol et kanté rebonds
chez castel ils étaient combien
attachant les cages ça gaze mondelange
salle des fêtes de montreuil troisième
mi temps mais ingère forever
en rémo forlani tué critique écrivain
auteur dramatique en laque république
gouttière chez ramsay c'est l'histoire
d'une petite chatte racontée par une
petite chatte celui-ci oui enfin le film
s'attache ici parce que bon c'est
l'histoire d'une charte que je prends à
sa naissance voilà le malheur de naître
chez des gens qui ont peu envie d'avoir
une chatte de gouttière dont il avait
dans un sac en plastique puisqu'ils
arrivent à la plupart des chats pour
prouver elle est sauvée heureusement ça
y aurait pas de bouquins donc moi je les
sauver et bondit c'est l'histoire de une
petite chatte qui cherche sa place au
soleil ce qui le problème de tous les
chats et je crois que tous les êtres
humains d'ailleurs et on essaie de
trouver l'endroit où on sera bien les
gens à qui on sera bien alors parce
qu'ils me permettent de raconter les
faire un roman qu'on voit vraiment c'est
celle que naturalisé eux à beaune là tu
fais allusion à une chatte qui est chez
moi et effectivement j'ai eu une shot
qui s'appelait l'uci ouais un peu servi
de modèle
oui et un jour allez vous enfin une nuit
est venue mourir dans mon lit je dormais
j'attendais la maison de petit oui j'ai
rallumé peuvent faire des mémos
errements et j'ai pas aimé ça et je les
ai emmenés chez deyrolle lors du match
nice c'est pas de la pub c'est un
naturaliste un monsieur qui s'occupe des
animaux il fait des éléphants les
sardines de secours eux et ils la
naturaliser mach ap enfin je les ai je
dit c'est qu'elle continue à dormir à
livrer sur le même fauteuil je ferme est
ouverte on a des petits jeux envers
entrouvert elle et elle dort c'est
inquiétant après d'avoir ça la maison il
ya bien des cimetières dans paris
cinquième personne un pouvoir qu'on
suppose de l'enfer la chaise qui
inquiète maintenant c'est pareil je
dirais quand etc est aussi
sur commande
des 80 s arrête pas avec les chattes et
c'est un bouquin qui s'appelait pour
l'amant de finale déjà vous souhaitez
vous rester l'histoire d'une fille qui
s'appelait tous les chats bon c'est pas
vraiment une histoire de chat enfin tous
les chats sont rendus ce genre il faut
dire oui j'aime les merdes enfin c'est
pas pour tout le monde tout le monde a
pas beaucoup de gens aiment les chats
j'adore les chats
c'est grave mais non c'est pas grave je
veux d'abord vaut mieux aimer les sharks
ne pas les aimer il ya autour mieux aimé
que pas aimé e bonds ont besoin ils
trouvent que je les connais bien ça
m'amuse j'aime ça m'amuse leur parler
c'est joli ça fait partie des joies de
la vie je veux dire les vitamines pièce
qui s'appelait chat aussi avec un accent
ibérique s'est pas joué et c'est
jacqueline là l'histoire
oui c'est l'histoire d'un couple qui se
sépare et puis ils ont ils ont pas
l'enfant ils ont un chat oui tu peux la
jouer lawrence à la légère le monsieur
non mais je vous embauche quoi c'est pas
jouer je joue avec un jour beazley je
suis pas maintenant clp c'est la tranche
pas combien cinq ans je me pour bosser
le passé je mange ou boit ça l'a fait
mais bien des cas serait fait un maximum
gens j'ai dû écrire aux pièces il y en a
eu neuf de jouer depuis voilà quoi et
c'est vrai que tu es le sport parce que
ton chat était écrasée par la caravane
du tour de france c'est vrai que quand
j'étais petit garçon il y avait déjà le
tour de france quand même avec chambres
sous toi la ville palace avec jeanne
songe à raymond souplex j'ai connu est
né après le tour de france est reçue
mais après le premier tour de france
meubles vêtements mais quand même j'ai
grandi en france à l'époque je sais pas
on time and baby soins beauté kg alfredo
binda ce jeu bon joueur bon et la
caravane devance auxerre rochefort en
yvelines on était sorti toute la famille
pour voir passer ces connards jeudi
ségolène s'est écrasé mon chat c'est un
vélo quand même non je pensais à des
camions nature boire depuis j'aime pas
le sport n'était pas catho fil par par
dégoût du genre humain quand même
non pas du tout pas du tout il ya déjà
ou non le gauthey les autos pas du tout
non moi je vous dire des gens si je
reviens je t'en pense qu'en tout juste
40 comme un chat quand tu veux
[Musique]
mais là
olé
[Musique]
le faire la la il est monté bon
là
et
[Musique]
bâle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dany heatley
qui ça
a city l'attend il est là
moi oui
ap
allah
[Musique]
à
elle est là
il est monté
courtrai
l'aah
[Musique]
la vie
ah mais
[Musique]
non
il l'avait
[Musique]
les seuls cantons areva
c'est là
l'upa
je me joue des tours
le père
[Applaudissements]
il
c'était le grand ordinaire qui chantait
tout va bien juste avant la fin lucien
riz le sur larbi chaud tout l'anneau
taille très chaud plus dur si cette fois
ci c'est vraiment fini leurs pales en
trois mois tu auras de nouvelles
lunettes les sept noires pour nuits
blanches salut bande d'alain resnais
est enfermé le jour en soit
voilée ma seule est lucho
[Musique]
oui
ce que
bah
auj
g
[Musique]
bah
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu